welcome back to new rock stars we have
fun here we like to laugh we create a
safe environment
thor four is confirmed to cast another
marvel hero
this time chris pratt peter quill
star-lord
uh what was burke macklin fbi of the
guardians of the galaxy that come and
get your love
in love and thunder are the two idiots
who are responsible for letting thanos
snap in infinity war finally going to
apologize to us at least that's how my
fan fiction has gone
i am tommy bechtold and this is rogue
theory the show that brings you
the nerdy hot takes on the topics we
can't stop talking about
eric voss is dead no just kidding he's
off today so chaos will rain
down is up right is wrong and fun will
be had by all
with me to go rogue today is writer and
comedian jessica clements hello jessica
oh hello tommy not eric boss who's not
dead he's just off
he's very much alive everyone but to me
he's dead and he knows why
uh also joining us today is twitch
partner host and musician angelica trey
hello angelica how are you hi
good to be back i'm excited to talk some
nerdy stuff
yes yes and for the first time ever we
are so happy to welcome to the show
host and producer at vids blessing eddie
oh yeah hello blessing how are you
yo what's up many guys are eric foss but
i love you all the same
that's true listen at the core of this
there is one
fundamental problem with this episode
and that's that none of us are eric vos
so
at the end of the episode we'll all do
our best eric vos impressions
just to get everyone rolling mine's
gonna sound like this
[Music]
because that's what it's eric is that
you that's aaron
he just felt like he was here for a
second yeah his spirit is with us and it
will be with us for the rest of our
lives because that's what happens when a
person passes on to you
emotionally and which is what has
happened he is very physically alive
but of course as i've said before very
much dead to me
anyway the hollywood reporter confirmed
this week that chris pratt is going to
be in the upcoming
fourth thor movie fourth order movie say
that three times fast guys
fourth movie fourth order fourth
fourth four movie just like one word
i'm gonna have a thorgy with the
hemsworth brothers all right let's go
love
don't we all love and thunder this makes
some sense as the last time we saw both
thor and press peter quill characters
they were flying off in the benatar with
the rest of the guardians of the galaxy
so they were all together hanging out
we're assuming peter quill is going to
be
a significant part in this movie's plot
and not just a cameo
although chris pratt's probably
available on cameo for like 400
he'll break up with your boyfriend for
you we also know that natalie portman's
jane foster will be returning
and that christian bale will yell at a
sound man
on this set because he has been cast in
a yet unnamed role
so gang friends posse crew
pitch me on how peter quill will cross
over into the thor 4
plot and how this might set up guardians
of the galaxy 3.
uh jessica we'll start with you so thor
4 which we're all very excited we're all
very stoked for
we know chris pratt's coming in i think
he's coming in as asgardian of the
galaxies i think we're gonna still get
that mesh between the two
i think we're gonna still get that
captain co rivalry that we had before
that we think is very funny and all
those bits
and this time they're going on bigger
cases they're going on bigger
jumps they're going on bigger missions
and one of those missions is to get
the necro sword so i think they're going
on their trial they're going through
space to go get the necro sword which is
actually
a trap while they're going to get the
necro sword they're going to
fall into a trap by gore the butcher so
and that is going to be played
by christian bale i know that everyone
online is kind of talking about this too
and i agree with every single voice
online that thinks it's going to be gore
the butcher
because that would be so sick to make
especially while we're getting like
black adam on the other side i think
these are two villains that are
justifiably villains that are like
kind of like killmonger where it's like
it's justified slightly
i get where they're coming from yes uh
so i really want to see him come in and
i think that's what christian bill's
playing and when he's in cat when he's
incapacitated
thor that's when they're gonna be like
oh who can we get to get on board with
this and that's when we're gonna get
jane foster as mighty thor
and i think yes and i think that quill's
gonna be very attached to jane foster
because this is going to be jane foster
that's also dying of cancer and
simultaneously turning into mighty thor
i think that's the kind of connection
that cool's going to have that's going
to feel that like
bond that he had with his mother that's
not there because she also died of
cancer she
also died of cancer so i think that's
how we're going to get jane foster
coming in here we're not getting rid of
thor completely
i think we're just going to get jane
foster appearing to help the guardians
to actually come and like destroy
christian bales gore
and that's how we're going to get
christian or christian pratt
that's how we're going to get christian
brat no the way we're going to get
christian pratt is to read my erotic fan
fiction because he
called chris you have to give me credit
i don't under no no no no no no no i
wanna credit on that
this will be like edited by justice like
the uh batman bill finger
uh bob kane thing where we'll credit you
later in life we'll give you
okay but directly put you in after i
make all of my millions off of christian
pratt
i love it uh i think that makes that
makes a lot of sense
i uh i could absolutely see that being
the way that they bring them in
uh i like that the uh the thematic
uh the desire for uh chris
chris pratt's character peter quill to
maybe possibly try and save
jane foster because he couldn't save his
mother i'm leaping to all sorts of
conclusions here but i'm going to award
you for this
not one child oh my god
uh as it was my birthday all i got from
my family were baby
so i'm getting oh my gosh baby yoda's
if that wasn't your birthday gift i'd be
like can you please bring me one
just one i don't know that i can take
care of all of them i think i fed one of
them after midnight and they just keep
multiplying
oh my god you should have never taken
care it shouldn't be me i should be
their mom
they mean everything so i understand
that how that goes that's true they love
eggs and
whole frogs all right angelico what do
you got for us
okay so i like the gore
edition so i'm gonna see if maybe i can
tie that into mine
but i'm thinking instead of peter cool
coming in as
a savior maybe he's gonna be adding some
trouble instead
peter quill gets kidnapped because he
gets in some heavy heavy gambling debt
and to get out of it he gives up four
thinking that the god of thunder is
going to be able to just
beat down all of these enemies but
little does quill
know that it's actually gore
the enemy and gore takes down asgardians
so he's essentially causing thor's doom
or just leading him into maybe some
ass kicking an epic proportion yeah
i'm thinking i'm here for it yeah so
he's like he's causing the trouble here
ah i like that cowboy style
i i love the return to guardians one
when they were like
all scumbags with hearts of gold is like
what it like they all started off bad
i think sometimes the problem with
superhero movies
in my opinion is that once you get to
the third or fourth movie
all of the original character traits of
the characters have been washed away and
they're just these like
do-gooding gods who like are like just
here to save people and do acts of good
and we forget what made them so uh
relatable in the first place which for
me is natural roots
yeah and for me as a person who's lost
tons of money gambling on sports i could
really relate to that so uh mommy
yes let's just see uh
i'm gonna say not one not two but again
also three
baby yodas for you as well look at that
the triplets uh
it's too much i gotta say it's a serious
episode with the frog man i cried at
that too
i think i just need a frog baby i think
i think
i think we could just get you a small
aquarium and like a frog and
you know i think you could we can find
some real happiness here
just cry staring at my fingers on the
glass all the time i'm
just crying at it i love it
all right blessing you're up your first
rogue theory let's go
oh god all right so one of the things
that i really like about the mcu is how
they take characters
and interpret them in their own way and
so like i really like thanos because
as far as i understood thanos because
i'm not i'm not like the biggest comic
book person you know when it comes to
knowing all the different lore and all
the different issues
uh but i do love watching movies and i
do love getting the interpretation of
the mcu
and going into avengers infinity war in
avengers end game
also the understanding that thanos was
this guy who would come through
conqueror of worlds just wanted to wreak
havoc
bring death across the land and the way
that
avengers infinity war and avengers end
game interpreted thanos was as this dude
who
has this like honest like personal
mission of wanting to bring good to the
world
by killing everybody and like i think
that's a cool cool thing i think that's
a cool idea to take the central idea of
thanos and then
twist that and turn that into something
that fits in
what the mcu has established as its own
universe and so i like what you guys are
saying about gore
i think we do the same thing uh i went
and did a little bit of research about
gore
for this specific video because i was
like i wonder gore's probably gonna come
up right
and the way the way that gore is
described right i'm looking at
specifically at the marvel fandom
website
uh they talk about how gore gore the god
butcher was
born on a planet with no name almost
every day was on the brink of brink of
starvation
uh uh his family died he suffered he
suffered a whole bunch
and that's why he hates the gods because
he was like there's no way gods exist
and they discover that gods exist and
he's like
i'm going to go after the gods because
screw them gods i don't like those guys
and so i think we take that idea and we
twist it in the mcu way
where now we look at we look at chris
pratt we look at thor
what do those two have in common or
peter quill not chris pratt what do
peter quill and thor have in common
they're both gods
i'd like to say they're both yummies yes
i mean that too
it might be both their fault that thanos
won an infinity war but
when it comes down to it as it relates
to gore they're both gods
and so the way i see it right is somehow
the offensive end game
messed up gore's life real bad right
like he
maybe he gets snapped away and then gets
snapped back and all of a sudden like
his family is gone
and he realized that his family died in
the five years or something like
something along the lines of that
happened
he realized he couldn't protect them uh
and he like makes a vow where he's like
all right like any god or god adjacent
being
must be stopped we i can't allow this to
happen again because it's your
your guy's fault that my family is gone
and i have to put a stop to this
and so gore goes after thor and goes
after uh i keep wanting to call him
chris pratt
goes after peter quill uh basically in
his mission to kill all gods
and that's how we lube in jane jane
isn't a god
uh and i don't know i don't know how he
get from point a to point b but somehow
thor and and i'm just gonna say chris
pratt for now on thor
and chris pratt enlisted the help of
jane uh in order to stop gore and i
don't know if it's
thor gives jaina a specific weapon or
thor
transfers his own power to jane but jane
comes in jaime comes uh
becomes a lady thor and that's how
things get solved
i love it i uh i was all set to give you
three baby yodas of your own for your
theory which was wonderful
great theory but then you committed a
fatal sin you admitted that you're not
uh uh the most knowledgeable person
about comic books and as we all know on
new rockstars based on
both our our shows and the comment
section belligerent insistence that
you're a genius
is what gets you success on this channel
okay you cannot admit failure
you cannot admit weakness but then you
did something that was near and dear to
my heart that earned you back the three
baby yodas and that is
you just called peter quill by chris
pratt's name
which is what i do every time and what
they say in the comments
i don't say the right names i say the
names that are around
in the universe of the character so for
that blessing for being
so wonderful in your first rogue theory
i award you this rollercoaster ride of
three baby yodas
yes thank you so much i appreciate it
i love the three baby otis so much guys
as you know i'm very stingy with the uh
rogi's oriotas
and so the fact that you all got three
is a good sign of things to come for
later on this episode we're going to dig
into the mystery behind
the major star wars character about to
show up in the mandalorian but first
quick word from our friends and my
personal saviors at manscaped
winter is coming was both a catchphrase
for game of thrones and is technically a
fact now
in november and for anyone named winter
a sign of good things to come
just because many of us are bundling up
and peering longingly out our windows
like jon snow
standing it north of the wall doesn't
mean we need to completely abandon our
grooming routines it's important to keep
a nice
trim chest area for the for the fires
you don't want the the embers to catch
your your manly chest hairs and burn
your chest up you want to keep it
waxed like me just smooth like a bowling
floor manscape's new lawnmower 3.0
trimmer is waterproof with advanced skin
safe technology
to reduce nicks and cuts and even as a
light to help you out when you're doing
some work where the sun don't shine
and by god if i haven't been waiting for
a light to shine down there
ah the weed whacker ear and nose trimmer
can help you whack those nasty weeds
in your delicate holes i can't make this
up
it has proprietary skin safe technology
as i said to help prevent
nicks and snags the north remembers
to always keep yourself trimmed up okay
so
let's just say you said i can't afford a
manscape in this economy
well get 20 off and free shipping with
the code rogue theory at manscape.com
that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
use the code rogue theory be sure to
join the manscape movement
these products are snow joke oh
zach off-screen producer zach wrote that
and he got he almost got me to laugh out
loud i almost got me to lol but instead
i'm just gonna
think about my manscaper which is no
joke to me it's no joke to me
and also we want to give a quick shout
out to the new rockstars merch store
this store has it all
uh newrockstarsmerch.com so many great
items hats shirts hoodies masks ball
gags kidding about one of those guess
which one
i'm going to get a high i'm eric voss
shirt because
i want to remember my friend who is as i
said very much alive but dead to me
emotionally
our custom mandalorian this is the way
shirt is selling like hotcakes so grab
one
of those before they're gone but don't
try and get it in red as i did because
it's sold out in red
you can only get it in black the site is
newrockstarsmerch.com that's
newrockstarsmerch.com
to get all your shirts and hats anyway
uh quick shout out to our patreon and
fellow detroit tigers fan feral jeff yes
jeff look at this get a tattoo on your
arm like me when you're 18 and you can
be a fan of the team forever whether
they're good or bad uh
pharaoh jeff won this week's discord
rogue theory contest
on our patreon-only discord servers
their pitch for the thor four plot
featured a de-powered thor
teaming up with star-lord and mighty
thor jane great stuff
to play along in future rogue theories
become a patron by going to patreon.com
new rockstars and be like pharaoh jeff
and i and participate in the football
picks pool
pharaoh jeff and i have been competing
for three weeks now and it's getting
intense in there and
just because he's a tigers fan doesn't
mean he's not my mortal enemy
on sundays anyway topic two in the most
recent episode of the mandalorian our
main character dinjarin
met fellow mandalorian bo katan who sent
our dude and baby yoda of
our dude sent our dude and baby yoda off
to look for a jedi
ahsoka tano on the planet corvus
and as i said corvus is where the party
is at
that's a you have to watch all of the
shows that i do on this channel to get
that what has ahsoka been up to
and what is she going to think of mando
and baby yoda blessing we'll start with
you first this time
ahsoka has set up a jedi training
sanctuary in corvus
that's right we're going the last jedi
route and so just like just like luke's
soon will uh her jedi training facility
has failed
uh a jedi turned bad burnt the place
down
burnt into a crisp she's like luke now
she's bitter
uh she's wishing the jedi would just die
off and then when
when when mando i just call amanda when
mando and
baby yoda get there she's like hey we
should probably kill this thing
because we shouldn't be having this
thing out here with all these powers
able to cause destruction able to cause
chaos etc
etc uh she pro she proposes killing the
child but
before she can do before she or it can
do any harm i guess
uh she warms up to baby yoda after they
have like this
this forced connection right somehow she
reads
she reads baby yoda's past learns about
how
baby yoda narrowly escaped
order 66 she learns how baby yoda may or
may not have
gone face to face with vader and barely
escaped that
uh and through that she warms up to baby
yoda
and through that they basically like
start this bond and she figures
she finds new meaning uh into partnering
with baby yoda and lead
leading baby ota forward ah i like that
a redemptions of sorts and uh maybe a
little more satisfying than luke's
redemption
uh but it is interesting like the it
does make sense because these jedis
are we're made to believe in the
original trilogy the jedi are like this
incredible amazing thing and then
everything that has come out since
paints them as like kind of petty jaded
angry people so i wonder uh if this is a
chance then swing it back to
uh to a jedi being a four so i mean
they're always forces of good but maybe
maybe more of a uh back on a positive
swing for the jedi
i am going to award you not one
cartwheeling baby yoda for this one oh
cartwheels
not two cartwheeling baby yodas
oh my god give you three cartwheeling
baby yodas for this look at this
this one this one's really showing off
for you oh he's going backwards wow how
many cartwheeling baby yodas
does it take to defeat vader uh well
that's a great question i think we'll
let angelica answer that angelica you're
next
he's eight at least eight that's true
okay so i'm thinking
all right so ahsoka is on corvus
and corvus has kaladan
just tying it to my my dune references
because i love dune
and there's a lot of ties here with it
but a caledon
is another dune reference to calidan the
home planet of house atreides
and with tatooine essentially being the
star wars version of arrakis
this could possibly foretell ahsoka
you know traveling from
kaladyan to tatooine maybe to visit
obi-wan's place maybe for
her old saber or something and boom
that's when tuscan boba fett attacks
i'm thinking this will like tie into
foiling like a plot to harvest
baby yoda's blood for cloning or
something
it's gonna get real epic though um
i like it yeah i like it very much yes
uh
anytime we can get boba fett back in
action anytime we can compare dune
to star wars and just make my brain fold
in on itself trying to
remember all of the details of all of
those things i'm in
space space uh i'm gonna give you not
one
moonwalking baby yoda not two moon
walking baby yodas
but three moonwalking baby yodas
oh it's so cute and they're good dancers
and they all look at they're all showing
off for you this time
i'm a grown man who plays with dolls
yeah
all right i'm a grown man that plays
with dogs
okay jessica let's go
you're up so let's think about it let's
think about let's
take a seat down um i like how i start
every session like
your aunt so if if i was her
if i was a sakitano what would i would
be doing what would i what
what would i do and i'm really thinking
about this realistically
and as herself she's been going through
everything her entire life and now that
she got away
and she's just dealing with her now
today like
herself as an adult woman she's probably
within hiding she's probably not trying
to be caught she's kind of laying low
but she still is there for justice
because that's what she stands for so i
feel like they're gonna find her
right and they're gonna find her in this
like kind of town where she
not like the first episode but kind of
like the first episode where
timothy oliphant's like the like sheriff
she's not the sheriff she's
she's laying low people are like this
girl is weird but they don't know that
she's actually been defending them for
like any kind of crime that's been
happening
and she's also trying to hide from the
people trying to start the empire back
up
so i think when she does see mando
amanda's like
yo she's like oh hell no and they start
fighting
she's like oh no and she takes off her
cloak and you see
that it's rosario dawson and she starts
fighting
and they're fighting and fighting and
then when the she like kicks over the
little like
huffle hover ball thing that baby yoda's
in and he comes
falling out and then that's when she
sees him and she's like
boom everything comes back to her she
knows everything she
already had this history in her mind
it's nothing new it's more so that she's
just like i remember this
i remember this baby i know this type of
creature i even know its name
and she does have all the information he
needs and now she's like
i have to help you we gotta go through
this together
and like every storyline has to go in
star wars she's gonna die at the end
and she's going to die fighting like 50
cent die trying die trying get rich or
die
trying get rich or die fighting die
fight
fighting
see tommy i we need to make a contract
because you are jumping off of my ideas
that was you i don't want money jessica
you can you can have all of my net worth
i hope you take
change uh you could you can have it all
okay
for you all right i do think she's gonna
be like dragged out of this like
deep retirement to fight back um and
i think that's just how realistically
it's like yeah she's tired as hell she's
been fighting her entire life and now
she's like
it ends today and that's how she's just
going to die at the end of the
series but you know yeah maybe she don't
maybe she shouldn't
stand a noble sacrifice this is uh
these are things familiar with the jedi
uh we're writing partners now so i don't
feel comfortable
uh be playing favorites with you so i'm
just gonna give you
three summer salting baby yodas look at
this like they're
the cartwheels were like this these ones
go like this
that is different still an adult
still playing with the dolls and i'll
leave don't even bring it up
i'll even give you one sound effect i
got to turn them on
hang on do it do it do it do it
okay
oh my god come on we
get you
we cast a spell on you did its eyes
close oh yeah
it moves so realistic i don't know if i
need that doll or if i just need a baby
[Music]
that's on par that's on par with the
practical effects
i'll be honest with you that's just a
plastic doll i wished him to life like
that okay it's not supposed to do that
i wished really hard and i woke up and
uh he started doing that
man all right guys so uh uh shockingly
as as is the case when i uh host
everyone's tied with rogies
uh at six which means the rogue question
is gonna decide our winner for today
and it's a banger this week is the 30th
anniversary of the release of the
original home alone
the macaulay culkin movie that inspired
millions of children to booby-trap their
homes
and slap their dads in the face with
paint cans which i think they discovered
physically would have killed whoever
that happened to
by decapitation a reboot is reportedly
in the works for this movie pitch me on
an updated 2020
home booby trap for the home alone
reboot
all i can think of is the arnold
schwarzenegger sound board yes yeah
use a sound board to
the intruders and
basically trick them into thinking that
they're sneaking into like
a celebrity house or arnold yeah
i like that yeah and then maybe like
i don't know maybe they'll want to steal
stuff more though i don't know if this
is working in my house
maybe they'd be more excited and more
likely to intrude
that's a good point but they're
definitely it does feel like there'll
have to be some element of like a tablet
that can
that can produce like video or audio
effects yeah i think
i think a terrible but a good way to
scare them away
is they leave the door open you know
leave the door open the old swinging
open door trick right they're already
like this is weird they come in
everything's pitch black they flip on
that light and you have fake blood
everywhere it looks like a crime
scene and then you lay there like a
murdered victim
enough where they're like i don't want
any part of this anymore
this is a house i don't want to rob
because now it looks like i am invested
in a crime scene
and they'll just leave i feel like if i
was here to burglarize on my house and
they were dead on the floor i'd be like
not this house
that'd be a deal breaker for you not
this house absolutely the stuff would be
haunted i'm not trying to deal with it
good good
absolutely couldn't agree more couldn't
agree more i guess for my life for me
i feel like this is close to the
soundboard ar uh idea
but what's more 2020 than video walls
what if what if you dug out your whole
your whole house
with a video wall set up where every
wall is a video wall and you basically
replicate the idea of
like a hall of mirrors where the robbers
walk in and they're like whoa like what
direction is the right direction you do
that with with video walls and you have
everything like
like you have you have basically uh
replicating hallways
you have uh like rooms folding into
themselves and basically confuse the
confuse the hell out of them you know i
haven't walked in there like where am i
well it doesn't seem very 2020 to make
the trap kind of be like inside your own
head like what you're thinking what
you're looking
at and what you're seeing is real
unfortunately the actual stereo
you're right exactly yes exactly
unfortunately the correct answer is you
lure them into the basement where you
have your cousin
who does crossfit and just turned vegan
is and then he tortures them by talking
about it for two hours
and that's what you talking about are
you the cousin do i look like i do
crossfit or yes
yes well that's because i do and i'd
love for all of you to try it
out basic plyometric exercises it's all
body weight stuff guys
you don't even need to own gym equipment
it's pretty simple by the way
if you're eating clean your body should
be ready to go anyway like an engine
think of your body as a car uh uh just
kidding
of course uh i i have to say i liked all
of them but in the end
uh a prison of your own mind is to me
the ultimate 2020 booby trap so blessing
in your debut episode of rogue theory
we're going to give you the win today
now was it explained to you that with
the win you get to uh
have a wish granted did you get that
part really yes oh man this is all i
i've always wanted to wish
you basically have 30 seconds to get us
to do or say or you can say whatever you
want
the next 30 seconds is yours to do what
you like with it
all right uh well if you want to keep up
with me and the work i do
i'm on twitter at blessing junior that
is at blessing jr i'm a part of
youtube.com
kind of funny games over there we do
video games content video games coverage
and so i host
a few days on california games daily
where we talk about video game news
i host on pslv xoxo where you talk about
playstation
uh i up here on kind of funny games cast
where we talk about the topic topical
game stuff
and so much more so head over to
counterfeiting.com
uh or kind of funny.com or youtube.com
kinda funnygames uh aside from that i
just wanna give a general psa of
hey like take care of yourself be good
to each other you know it might be a
rough year for us
all but that doesn't mean that we can't
put it put in an effort to be good to
each other and be positive and
try and show love even though sometimes
it's difficult uh and so take care of
yourself wear a mask you
go outside we go to places uh and be
mindful of others and be good
that was the nicest use of that space
we've ever had i've
never really seen that nice diabolical
eric vos filling that space
with his rancid voice and terrible
disgusting face
again he's very much alive but to me
remains dead
in in person he will never be alive to
me again he's wronged me in ways i
cannot describe
that's it for this episode of rogue
theory thanks to our guests they were
all amazing
follow them with their handles that are
being displayed below right now
don't forget to subscribe to rogue
theory podcast feed stay tuned to the
youtube channel
for this and other shows follow us on
twitter at new rockstars follow me at
tommy beck told
and follow eric voss to freedom just
kidding eric i love you this has all
been a joke
this was my prank i booby-trapped this
episode for you but in the end
the reward is three baby yodas
oh my god my sons
[Music]
you